hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're in my kitchen and we're
unboxing something that I am extremely
excited about it I saw this a few months
ago and it is a limited-edition matte
black KitchenAid it's called Black Tie
limited edition artisan series I'm not
even sure well that means all I know is
it's matte black and it's beautiful and
not only is the mixer itself matte black
but all the accessories I don't even
know what they're called the things that
you stick on the things this is exciting
it's time to unbox I've also got this
really nifty knife someone sent me time
to cut this knife is so sharp looks
inside there I have absolutely no idea
what this is there's a lot of stuff in
here
and PS this is not sponsored
congratulations on your purchase of a
KitchenAid limited edition artisan stand
mixer I'm number 212 baby oh my god
there's only 500 I thought they made a
thousand this is even more limited
edition than I thought I still haven't
flipped this though this is the selling
point I've learned that this is called a
dough hook I don't know what this one's
called
but I like this one a lot I basically
use this for everything wow it's so
pretty
welcome home you're gonna love it here
watch bottom together like the details
like it's really no this is not good do
you want to get a little peek of this of
this right here you see that it's
flaking off it's already messed up and I
didn't even do anything yet that's not
good look at that like I just opened it
I can't believe it's already messed up
it's absolutely beautiful though
directions that I probably won't look at
oh look at this little whiz
hand wash only good to know I don't
think I'll ever use this it's too pretty
I wonder if this will fit on my head is
a half okay well yes I've so many
problems but a matte black mix there
ain't one so I feel like I should mix
something but I don't think we're gonna
do that this is purely an unboxing today
oh you put this on here and you can put
your little ingredients in here so
doesn't splash everywhere when you're
mixing we've got recipes this is called
this is a French are you find the
English one it is called a flat beater
and the attachment knob is broke it's
chips I'm so upset
well guys that's it should we do like a
little slow most sexy shots of it
well thank you guys so much for watching
I'm so excited to bake with this it's
gonna be super super fun I've also been
preparing for a video one of my absolute
favorite tech youtubers mkbhd who I'm
sure all of you guys know his favorite
color is matte black he has matte black
everything keyboard air pots
everything so one of you guys tweeted
both of us and said you need to make a
matte black cake with mkbhd and I was
like all right so I said next time
you're in LA we're gonna do this I've
even been preparing hold on let me show
you something I have yet to ever try to
use fondant but I got this it's clearly
it's it's matte black fondant so I'm
gonna do some test baking with this and
see how that goes
but stay tuned for a future video
because I think it'll be super super
cool well that's all I've got for you
guys today thanks so much for watching I
will see you in the next video also let
me know what you guys want me to make
with this
[Music]
[Applause]